got to come with me now the girls were
going to become even more Scottish
bridges have you ever taken your
knickers off before no no chance to show
a mother okay it's time for Lua can a
small colony of French comrades to
surrender themselves to the Scots four
things I'll do to get the arrogant
French to become a little bit more
Scottish is amazing there's 25 very
important guests coming for lunch
yes but some really good news they're
all women if they can impress 25
influential local business women they'll
be the talk of the town
to forget one potato vegetarian very
upstate to follow one yogi
at last looook steel beginning to dance
for different tune
the food looks really good clear and
simple
I have everyone's Kevin really well for
the first time I've actually seen a real
taste of Scotland in this kitchen
he's cuckoo Fox
loic's on his way to the top of the
Premier League
and judging by the reaction of his fans
he's definitely scored you'd be talking
at least something like this in that
time skilled brilliant beautiful I think
it's a big chef what is that thank you
yeah chin chin chin
Louie and his team have come a long way
this week and if he sticks to my keep it
simple mantra and I think Lera Vieira
might be on the right track for a
mission star just for the ladies
register to understand that you really
are part of Scotland now we're all gonna
turn around
- right - right